I rolled my sleeves up on my t-shirt so
you think it's fashion welcome to
once-over Wednesdays or I'm wearing an
ill-fitting t-shirt that I've had since
fifth grade that says I'm a terrific kid
and I did my makeup so it must mean that
I'm going to review the Golden Gloves
fashions clearly I'm qualified I can't
spell qualified without life cue Sam
Naomi Watts looks like King Midas just
all over her beautiful Amy Adams may I
have an order from that chest plate
clever call me and teach me how you do
that with thanks and the tits very
pretty you from the show you look like a
bell not a southern belle like I felt it
doesn't thing didn't dig very pretty you
from the thing finally someone has found
a sophisticated way to wear a cape you
are my hero very pretty
Jennifer Lawrence took her hotel bed
sheet and put some headbands around it
very innovative and also kind of like a
wedding cake very pretty
Jessica Chastain who did that to your
ear and why did they do it did the
hotels not have a hairdryer or did it
have the biggest hairdryer ever very
pretty
Sofia Vergara we get it you are loud and
beautiful you look like a cake topper on
a funeral cake wedding very beautiful
Sandra Bullock I'm confused
I think it's good but maybe it's not
very pretty
Olivia Wilde Oh want to get her double
pregnant in this I like this very much
how do you do it who dipped you in a
glitter nail polish very pretty
Emma Watson this is my favorite because
the back of it is pants you are a mild
risk-taker and you just always look like
you know more than me
very pretty keep on check you're not for
you very pretty
Zoey's all down up who did this to you
what HGTV crafts host did this to you
big pretty Julia Roberts she's working
nine to five but she's like a movie star
whose superpower is being able to become
a secretary in five seconds
very pretty Reese Witherspoon never ages
ever
what are you very pretty well there you
go that's my ones of a review of a go to
clubs fashions do I have a rating system
to be determined what do you think
I don't know I'm just gonna reiterate
this but yesterday we announced the
official release date of Camp Takota it
is February 14th Valentine's Day so make
sure you go to camp Takota calm and free
order than bleep bread let the movie
that's the word got there and spend
Valentine's Day with us let's all have a
big group date no circle jerk